lava shot through another crack on
Hawaii's Big Island yesterday
threatening a nearby power plant it has
been one week since lava first burst
from the ground outside the Kilauea
volcano there are now 15 fissures the
lava flow covers 116 acres that's nearly
the size of 88 football fields that's
huge 36 buildings have been destroyed
Carter Evans is in Pahoa Hawaii Carter
good morning good morning the danger
isn't just that underground lava oozing
from those cracks in the ground
geologists also say there is an
increasing chance of explosions in the
volcano's main crater sounding like a
massive blowtorch fiery lava from
Kilauea continued a relentless crawl
down the streets of Leilani estates this
area has been under mandatory evacuation
since large cracks started appearing
across the community a week ago this
fissure opened up right in someone's
front yard you can see the lava stopped
just before reaching the home but the
air is still toxic I know some people
have defied the evacuation orders
they're still living inside there
they're gonna leave when the lava
reaches their door and it's become an
issue because we're gonna need to rescue
them at some point the active fissures
are lining up near a major geothermal
power plant which has now been shut down
but it still houses some 30,000 gallons
of flammable liquids it's a growing
concern for both the public in the
governor who wants the dangerous solvent
out by today we want to make sure that
we can remove it from the site as
quickly as possible heavy clouds of
smoke were seen coming from Kilauea
Wednesday likely triggered by a rock
fall from the crater walls as lava
levels inside the volcano decrease the
danger of an eruption can actually
increase when the molten rock reaches
ground water levels pressurized steam
can cause an explosion
shooty Roxanne - miles away from the
crater what is the biggest challenge for
the car going forward the biggest
challenge for the guard is not knowing
what's going to happen with the weather
changing new vents opening up we don't
know what's going to happen so we're
trying to prepare for the worst today
the threat of an explosive fault
panic eruption is an immediate concern
most of volcanoes national park will be
closed starting tomorrow there's also an
increasing threat of vog or volcanic fog
sweeping across the islands Nora Wow
Carter Evans in Hawaii thank you so much